all right I'm adeeb
um I'm the chief product officer here at
comma I lead the open pilot team and I'm
going to talk about how we actually ship
open pilot
um so we have a saying at comma we say
the difference is ship ability we've
been saying this since the beginning
it's a pretty important core tenant of
comma everything we do is designed to be
shippable we don't as Harold Joe we
don't really spend time on things that
we don't think we can ship we always
develop something to be at least have an
intermediary that we can ship first even
if we can't ship the very final system
um
so Harold showed you a bunch of cool
things that the research team develops
they tell the car where to go
um but then what do you do after that
you've got these really fancy machine
learning models they tell the car where
to drive how fast they drive and they
can even navigate now but how does that
get to you in open pilot
so first we need some Hardware
and this is what comes in your car it's
a lane keep camera
it's got a very tiny amount of compute
so unfortunately we can't run open pilot
on it
um
it's also got no video out but so we
don't get a raw camera stream out of it
um and it's different in every car so
that means for every car we'd have to
not only reverse engineer the messages
to read the state from the car and send
the actuation we'd also have to figure
out how to interface with it possibly
get a camera stream out of it
um and figure out how to run it on that
processor so this one has a mobile eye
chip uh
so instead
since we can't use this what we do is we
ship the comma 3 we launched that last
Comic-Con
and has everything you need to run open
pilot
it's got three cameras
it's got a Snapdragon 845 so every
single one has the same processor
whether you have a Toyota Corolla a
Hyundai Sonata or Honda Civic
and it's got enough compute to run
modern machine learning models and it
interfaces with every single car exactly
the same way
and the way we do this is we take pcbs
into our office and comma 3's come out
so the first step in this process is
something called circuit spoke
the original comma 3s you may have
bought towards last year's Comic-Con or
two years ago were made by a
manufacturer called circuit Hub we
replace them with something called
Circus book that's in our office ever
since we moved we've been running comma
threes there they come in with bare pcbs
just like that
and then they run through this line we
have a jet printer a pick in place an
oven and some fancy aoi
and then they get headed off to the
production room right over there
and then it goes off to assembly you can
see a bunch of comma three boards here
um lots of stuff on them
and then they get provisioned stress
tested
and you order them at shop.com with AI
we fulfill the next day we fulfill every
day
um
so
now we've got some Hardware
next we need to run on a car
so we know self-driving is entirely a
software problem
um but now we explain why we need to
start with Hardware
but fortunately we don't need to build a
car modern cars are more than good
enough they've got Lane keeping so we
can control the steering by using the
same inputs and the same with the gas
and the brakes
so here's the Toyota Prius very early
supported car for open pilot
um
so for each car we had Hardware to
attach the comma 3 that's a little bit
more specific than the comma 3 so every
pin out
um on the camera connector that I showed
previously is different
uh so we have a little bit of special
hardware for your car but the compute
isn't
and then we need some special software
for your car to read and write to it
and we've done this about 250 times
um for the 250 officially supported cars
and there's many many more in uh
community supported Forks
so this is the car harness
this is the uh
this is the end that goes into your car
this is the end that goes into the comma
three
each car and brand each brand and model
tend to need a different wiring harness
they provide Power and access to the can
bus and that's how we talk to the car
we have 34 different harnesses that
cover our 250 supported cars
um
so now that we're attached to the car we
need to be able to read and write from
it
so each brand again has its own messages
that needs to reverse engineered after
we've already connected to the car
um
and then we read a bunch of signals like
speed steering angle whether the cars at
standstill the steering torque that
you're putting on the wheel we read out
a whole bunch of things and then we need
to be able to send steering gas and
brakes to your car
all right now I'm going to talk about
something that's pretty exciting uh open
pilot safety
so this is something you don't expect uh
or you might not expect you know you
have a machine learning model that tells
you where to go we have a planner we
have a control stack
um but how do you constrain that output
how do you make how do you ship this in
a continual way where you don't have to
think about these things in this stack
how do we abstract out the safety from
this
so we have something called the open
path safety model and it guarantees a
couple things
so first it says that the driver must
always be able to take control of the
vehicle by stepping on the brake pedal
or the castle button so this means
you're able to engage openpilot and take
control whenever you want
um
and then we have this next point which
means
essentially open pilot can't react
um or do anything too quickly for an
attentive driver to not have enough time
to take over
so we enforce this safety and through
that openpilot is able to pretty much
make whatever decisions it wants and
it's constrained by the safety model as
long as we do a good job of enforcing
that
so there's some pretty good standards
around this that allow us to formalize
the safety model give it specific
actuation limits and uh give us a good
way to think about safety
so ISO 15622 gives us some good
guidelines for ACC
um
and then there's another ISO standard
11270 for Lane keep we recently updated
our safety documentation with some of
these actuation elements so that they're
more uh they're more formal you can go
in you can read these documents they're
very readable they're like 15 page PDFs
this stuff is very accessible and then
you have ISO 262 which is just kind of a
general framework for thinking about
functional safety for road vehicles
and then we have something called the
panda
um so the panda in your comma 3 doesn't
look quite like this
but this is an external Panda for can FD
cars
it's a secondary processor that directly
talks to the car
so a common thing you might see about
openpilot on the Internet is that you
know I don't want a phone driving my car
well the phone isn't driving your car
this is the thing that talks to your car
um I think it's an important point
because this is one of the coolest parts
of open pilot you know you can have a
fork and the panda protection you don't
touch the panda and uh you should be in
good shape
so the panda has all the code that
enforces the safety and it allows open
file to be something called qm
so there's this framework for thinking
about safety called Azle and it stands
for Automotive Safety Integrity level
and then there's something uh below the
Azle ratings called qm this stands for
Quality Management
um and what that means is
any
anything openpilot wants to do as long
as it's constrained properly by the
panda safety it's worse consider bad
quality it essentially has no safety
implications in regards to the safety
model
so when you're talking about open pilot
safety
first you should read the safety model
and then you should go okay is the panda
properly enforcing the safety model and
if that's the case then whenever
openpile makes a decision that you felt
was unsafe you have a proper way to
think about
um
whether this was
actually unsafe it provides some very
specific language to talk about this and
we're quite strict about how we
communicate this because it's really
important to think about it in this way
and the panda goes through loss of
testing and it has very rigorous code
standards we observe misery and all
relevant Automotive safety guidelines
there
and now I want to talk a little bit
about testing so you've got a system
but how do you continually ship it so we
ship open pilot updates to master
several times a day and we ship open
pilot updates to our release users
roughly every month
um and you might be surprised to know
that the releases go through very little
specific testing we have really great
testing infrastructure that we try to
get it as early as possible so that
means when we're pushing code directly
to master we expect to find those
failures pretty immediately on Master by
the time something hits release it's
pretty rare to find a bug you might have
noticed we don't really ship hot fix
this anymore things are getting quite
stable on that front and the zero nine
open pilot series
so back in 2016 there's a fun quote I
found this Commit This was uh well
before my time
towards the start of the company and it
says one day we'll have CI
so today we do have CI
and the test Suite looks a little bit
something like this we don't test in
cars this is the first principle if you
have to go down to a car first it's slow
all the cars are different
um it's not a good Loop
so we run regression tests in the cloud
with GitHub actions
we have Hardware in the loop tests that
run on tons and tons of real common
threes
and then we have dozens of comma threes
running open pilot continuously but the
CI is getting so good that these dozens
of comma threes really don't find
anything it's getting quite boring you
just see them driving and driving and
driving and it's
really pretty incredible the way we can
ship things now to open pilot master and
I don't know how many of you run master
or try to run the bleeding edge I
suspect many of you do if you show up
here
but I think you haven't seen a
regression in quite a while
so I want to talk a little about one of
our tests it's called process replay
and it allows us to deterministically
replay all of our driving processes so
that means you have the driving model
for example we give it the same video
and then we say okay what do the outputs
look like do they look exactly the same
for the same inputs
um
and this essentially outputs a diff in
the outputs of the process given two
commits so you can say I have this good
known Commit This is good known behavior
and what is the deviation from that good
known Behavior you get a green check
mark if there's no difference and if
there are differences it's really easy
to go in and say okay this is an
expected difference and then or this
isn't an expected difference and I
messed something up
and the real power on this is it makes
refactors essentially free
um you know when you're doing a refactor
and you you're changing something you're
like I don't really know if this is the
same you know you run it a little bit
and you're like okay this looks roughly
the same with process replay uh your
coverage is only constrained by the
inputs if you want more coverage you
throw more data at it you can generate
data that'll be relevant for what you're
doing but
um we just throw in lots of segments
from lots of different cars and we get
great coverage that runs on every single
open pile commit and gives you a diff
from the last known good open pilot
commit
so this allows I think research right
before the release merge a fairly large
refactored rate Rd
they are able to run it through process
replay and a larger version of process
Replay that they maintain and uh it was
I mean nobody was concerned about this
before the release it was just business
as usual
all right so this is uh kind of the most
important thing in testing green check
mark means good to go if you don't trust
your CI then
there's almost no point
so every time you commit you should be
very confident when you get that green
check mark that you're ready to merge
this and nothing is
nothing unexpected will happen
essentially
um sometimes there's there's good uh red
X's we have some cool tests like a power
draw test that asserts that essentially
every driving process doesn't use uh
more or less power than expected so
we've had some fun ones like that where
we've done some optimization you got a
red check mark and it's like okay I
lowered power usage and then we can
adjust the thresholds and we can say
this will not regress in the future
because we test this explicitly on every
single commit and it's similar with CPU
usage memory usage all those kinds of
things
all right so this robust testing
infrastructure enables us to ship open
pilot updates extremely regularly
there's essentially no uh bottleneck on
shipping to master you have a green
check mark then you're you you feel very
confident sometimes you might you know
ask somebody for a review but uh really
the machines are doing your reviews for
you they're enforcing essentially all
the behavior we want to enforce and this
allows us to support all the 400 plus
contributors we have now it's nearly
double since last Comic-Con and it's
pretty incredible we hit 10 000 commits
we've have
of those 10 000 commits I I think about
30 of them are from external
contributors
um who you know you can't expect an
external contributor to Too Much
validation it works on their device
works on their car improves their
experience
um but it's always hard to expect them
to do the validation uh when they're not
the ones clicking the merge button so
we've really removed that burden on
ourselves in the same way that they go
through the same workflow that we do to
validate our changes
and I think a really cool feature of
this is we have 250 supported cars this
has grown again double since last
Comic-Con I think it was 134 last
Comic-Con and it's a single engineer
maintaining all those cars we're
expanding car support we support all
major brands now we recently merged
support for Ford
um and it's uh
it allows the community to really uh
the community is really able to uh
leverage our CI and we just
we're able to validate their stuff so
quickly that uh we can have one person
who just builds test and infrastructure
for them and then we merge their
carports and it's a really great
pipeline now
all right so I want to talk a little bit
about what's next for open pilot now you
have an idea kind of how we ship up and
file it
um we ship little boxes to you guys I
showed you a little bit about the
procedure for that
um and then you know there's some
unexpected hiccups you know you need to
do some safety you need to do some
testing so that you can ensure that
you're continuously shippable but what
are we shipping next
so this is something from the taco video
we had to bump up the low speed torque
the way we implement the safety for our
torque based cars right now is
um it trades off some implementation
Simplicity for maximizing torque at all
speeds
um because for a essentially for a given
uh
you can only maximize
your lateral cell acceleration for a
given torque at
um but narrow speed range so that means
at the low end you're not getting as
much torque
um so in the future what we'll do is
we'll be able to look at the speed and
the panel will say okay you can get a
little bit more torque at the low end
and then we'll be able to give you a
consistent amount of lateral
acceleration across the whole speed
range rather than at one narrow point
where we maximize on the highway
um
and then this is another interesting one
coming up a lot of cars are coming out
as Vision only they don't have Radars
um so we've got to start doing comma a b
we want to this is a milestone that we
need to hit for openpile 1.0
um this is a video from when we did our
first a b tests
um what we're doing
some more of our
some safety work on uh
we wanted to validate that essentially
we passed through the the a b messages
and that it still works so this is the
first time we did that we built this car
this is how we do it and some systems
are a lot better than others you should
go to read the blog post I pulled this
picture from there it's really great we
analyze the
the manufacturer a b systems and we we
compare them we Benchmark them and we
can compare them even to open files for
Collision ordering which is really
pretty uh pretty good and really
suitable enough to ship an aab but then
again there's a lot of safety work
that's needed to ship AED you don't want
to just uh trigger at any time it also
extends the safety model we're going to
trigger when you're not engaged so
there's quite a bit of safety work that
goes into this
all right and then we want to ship to
more robots here I'll talk a little bit
about this this is going to require some
brief factors to support cleanly the
common body fit in pretty cleanly as a
car but we want to support more robots
you might have noticed the self-drived a
system refactor and open pilot we're
going to keep working on that and it
should be really easy to integrate in
any of your robotics projects
and then uh we're trying to make
everything more Plug and Play you might
have had the fingerprint your car I see
there's a lot of users here
um hopefully you didn't have to but this
is a metric we're starting to track now
we refer to as ttff
um that's a GPS acronym that stands for
time to First fix the open pile team is
a kind of commandeer to mean time to
first fingerprint so what this shows is
how many users every day didn't hit a
successful fingerprint who should have
essentially they bought a comma three
they saw their Toyota Corolla was
supported they put it in their car and
it said car and recognized so this is
something we're fixing it turns out we
uh we were very concerned in the
beginning we pinned to exact like these
firmware strings we get from the car
and it turns out you know they don't
change their apis that often we can look
at these firmware versions a little bit
more and we can essentially if we say we
support the Toyota Corolla you plug in a
comma three it'll just work so we ship
the first version of that for Hyundai's
in 093 Toyota's are coming up next and
we'll extend it to all the cars
all right and now I want to shout out
our external contributors we have 474 as
of uh this morning
so
if we can get a developers developers
Developers for our external contributors
in three two one
development Developers
all right time for questions
[Applause]
so you can ask me questions about open
pilot the product the production process
really anything like that
no so we actually run these on the CPU
in GitHub actions
yeah
yes
um so there's actually some Brands where
the EPS does this for you so like the
Chevy bolt is like this
yeah
so the question is
um like what's the best car brand or or
even model specific model that has like
the uh the highest low speed torque
limit
so there's some cars that are uh all
these apis are different amongst the
cars the Chevy bolt happens to be one
that already has good low speed torque
because they already compensate for this
when you request the torque so that's
one you can get right now that'll have
really great low speed torque
all right I'm back here
thanks so much for your presentation I
always love anything on CI
um so
in in your replays I guess you're you're
kind of trying to see if the car or or
the new release yeah does the proper
behavior again you don't have a
regression do you have any and I'm
asking this because I'm kind of
interested in this this project called
Vision zero right
um
do you do you have any testing
techniques or know of any testing
techniques for say reproducing Adverse
Events like collisions like can you kind
of test for hey it is a certain type of
behavior in a car actually cause a
collision so these tests are a little
bit different they're lower level than
that
so what we test for is we take each
individual process and processes really
only do uh they have very narrow Scopes
so we'll say like is the car parsing are
we taking canned messages and we say did
we parse the same car state out from
this
um so it's much lower level you probably
want to ask the research team this
question they have really great tests
for this stuff
thanks so much for that feedback it's
super useful
uh yeah can you talk a little bit about
your segments you use for testing and
validation you mentioned um do you are
you kind of continually changing those
out over time as you get fresher data
for off of more recent open pilot
versions or is it kind of just one big
list of segments that you're
continuously building on over time
so the big list we build on over time is
the ones for cars
um we have several test segments for
each car we support and we have like
this 200 line unit test it's really
great and it basically ensures the cars
never break
um this was this turned out to be a
problem up until maybe a year or two ago
where uh you know there'd be some minor
regression in all these cars especially
since we don't have one from each
platform
so that one we continue to build on over
time for other tests you generally get a
pretty good coverage
from so we have to update them
occasionally when there's new outputs
and new inputs but uh largely no we
don't have to the next step for this is
like fuzzy testing and you want to
really search over that whole space and
make sure you get full coverage
and generate the data
yeah
I have a question um which car brands
are the easiest to support and the
hardest to support and do you have any
thoughts on their software engineering
practices and quality
um so easy as a sport this is really
changing now actually the software
platforms and the cars at least for the
eight ass were pretty stable for about
like three four years and we did a lot
of this initial work maybe three four
years ago and now we're in this cycle
where you know Honda Toyota Hyundai a
lot of them are changing their their
platforms right at the same time so
that's the hard part right now is we're
getting kind of this influx that are all
different right now
um the hardest ones now are the ones
that implement the autosar secure
onboard communication
we haven't spent much time on it but uh
that'll be a little bit of a project it
just adds more overhead to porting a car
yeah I think you had a second question
oh
um I mean we reverse everything so
sometimes we see some fun stuff but
largely it's you know it's the practices
of the tier one
um the worst part is sometimes the apis
just don't make any sense at all and we
have to hack around that
hi I have a question on the community
collaboration so
um what's the expectation as far as for
you know proper communication and also
the quality of the PRS that we do like
what's that like and uh we have a lot of
PRS that's been you know being
um opened with cut with the open pilot
repo but yeah always getting a lot of
time at the time to get a merge or get
them you know even review is a long time
so what's the expectation that the
external developers or collaborators
should be expecting
so
um as far as communication
um
we tend to merge the things that are
pretty immediately mergeable pretty
quickly and then we have to prioritize
essentially what is valuable to us right
now
um there's a lot of the ones that are
open are
um
maybe there's like a lot of refactors
that are like of questionable value that
maybe we should just close
um and perhaps we should have some kind
of Auto close mechanism that's we can
certainly improve this but uh for things
that are like pretty immediately
valuable we'll try to provide good
feedback
um immediately and try to get them
merged but it essentially goes through
the same prioritization as the stuff we
work on it's it's really quite a small
team that's looking at this stuff
hi so um for all the testings are being
done on open pilot what's the process
like of uh developing a test case
developing a test case Okay so usually
the way this works is you write
something and then you say okay I'm not
sure if this is uh this is going to work
quite the way I expect then you're in
the test case
um so generally we have a lot of the
kind of General test cases that are end
to end it's written already and then now
it's more of a specific unit test cases
that get written I mean you can look at
the I was looking at the open about
commit history this morning actually to
get a nice picture for something and uh
it's like mostly tests so that's what
you see these days things that like
regress a little bit and we write a test
form we say okay this is never
regressing again
hey uh just wondering if you could share
any insights into your aeb deep dive
which brands did well which brands did
not
so
Honda Bosch I believe was uh
was the worst performing um it was
actually fun when we were testing it we
had to put a license plate on it I think
we have to put a German license plate to
get it to trigger
um yeah so the funny thing is they
released the testing procedure so you
can kind of engineer it
um it's kind of like the fuel emission
stuff where you know sometimes they
engineer a sort of demo essentially for
when they do the test
um but again it's we'd have to like
fully reverse the systems to understand
how it works it might have actually been
looking for something that was real
um but it's probably time to redo that
test we support a lot more cars now and
we can redo that blog post
um I had a question on steer torque do
you only do you only use torque for uh
rate limiting or do you use steer angle
ever
uh so it depends on the car we
essentially want to limit the the two
things we want to limit our lateral
acceleration and jerk these are actually
specified in ISO 11270
um so we have to limit essentially what
the car gives us we develop a safety
model or a safe an implementation of the
safety model for each car as it comes we
recently supported the Fords
um
and those you know they don't take
torque
um we give it curvature we have to
develop something around that um
fortunately for a lot of the eps's or
don't provide enough torque the that
exceed the iso 11 270 limits some do
um and we but we implement the safety
nonetheless for all of them
you spoke a lot about Cloud testing with
CI but you sometimes do Hardware in the
loop tests so can you elaborate more on
how and when you do those and any best
practices you adhere to yeah so the best
practice here is we do them on every
single commit
um they're
if the test is something you have to run
manually it's just not going to get done
sometimes uh you're less likely to also
make the change that you want to make
um the the best feeling about CI is like
you know when you're at home you want to
make a change and you're like you know
oh well it's public it's really easy to
like go on the GitHub editor it's like
oh let me make this quick change and
it's like do I commit to master the
small change do you open a PR
um
and uh you see the green check and use
merger it's like I don't feel like it's
gonna
you feel really good that it's not going
to break master and I do this pretty
often where I go home at night I'm like
oh I want to make this quick change I
end up merging it that night go to sleep
and I'm not worried it's going to break
Master because we do have like 400 users
who run the very very bleeding edge
um so if it does break Master they'll
let us know pretty quickly
hi um
it sounds like you do uh a
a
CI on pretty much every commit yep um
does that also go for uh hardware and
loop testing or is that more less
frequent rather nope okay on every
single commit and in that case
um
how how long do you run those Hardware
in the loop tests because I've seen open
pilot bugs that don't manifest until the
comma has been running for a few days
um like what kind of bugs like uh uh low
IPC rate errors
um a failure to engage after being on
um doesn't turn off when the battery
gets low things like that do you run a
fork no just a regular release channel
oh okay we should talk about that after
maybe but uh so we have some different
infrastructure for that we call it the
testing closet because it actually
started in a closet and our maybe two
offices ago when we were in a house and
it's essentially just dozens of comma
threes running continuously
um
and the hardware and the loop test are
like normal unit tests that need to run
on the real Hardware to validate some
some things that we can't reproduce on
like Cloud CI Runners like using the DSP
and the 845
a lot of question uh what motivated the
desire to actually assemble the pcbs and
Boards in-house like what problems did
you guys run into from so contract
manufacturers we uh use this company
called circuit Hub and you know we got
bored under the bus
yeah things got too complicated and now
that we have this it was uh it's really
incredible for prototyping we can like
essentially have CI order boards every
Friday and it makes so much sense it's
like 200 for a bunch of boards we just
run them through the line it's really
fast and easy uh doing revs with the
comma 3 took forever
um
so it's uh it's really a superpower in
that regard too but we've been doing
some really great tuning over the last
couple weeks on the line and uh finding
like the really littlest things we cash
into production we stop the line
immediately we go and fix the thing you
know and we're able to do the same
things we do in production but on the
boards themselves
here we can tweak every little detail
yes
I I just have a question on capacity we
ever have capacity shoes ever and
multiple users in uh using the software
whatever or something like that it does
that ever called Peak and have to
distribute it
I'm sorry what kind of issues uh
my question is related to capacity so oh
capacity issues yes I've ever run out of
capacity issues and then how it
distributed multiple user using the same
time like does that the peak you know
the peak volumes for that multiple users
are using at the same time yes well
everything runs on your device so
there's no issues like that you don't
need to connect to the cloud except for
navigate on open pilot but that just
hits like a tile server and a routing
server so uh the load is pretty low
there
uh do you have any kind of special
process to integrate tests for driving
feedback you get from users for like
consistent disengagement spots across
open Violet versions
um like for instance there's an express
lane that I drive on and it's
consistently taking tried to take the
exit across you know
op0909192 it did good on the way to the
airport a few days ago on 94 but I had a
lead car in front of me so I think that
definitely played into it
um driving behavior questions are
generally best asked for the research
team wishing is going to have some
really great stuff on this
um on like this engagement analysis
um we have a driving feedback Channel
Discord where there's like a nice form
you give it a route as long as you
upload all your logs so the if you ever
want something looked into by us we love
looking at the bug reports but they have
to be you know you have to put in the
effort to make it really high quality
um I mean just put in the effort and
it'll be high quality so don't worry too
much about like don't worry whether it
is high quality so just continue to make
the reports because I've reported them
all you know I try to talk about the
feedback but um just was curious if you
had a specific process to like
prioritize those or you know kind of
make sure that there's no regressions
um so we do look at everything in that
channel we look at everything that's
reported essentially and we
if it's something that looks a little
bit concerning or that looks like a
regression will evaluate whether it
actually is or it progressed in like
some very minor cases and we we
prioritize that way we do look at
everything that comes in so thank you
it's not always easy to respond to
though
yeah generally I would just like to
thank everyone who's made a good bug
report I think people don't realize how
valuable yes give it up for bug
reporters
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that slide really should have been
bug reports bug reports bug reports you
truly I think people may not really
fully realize how valuable the reports
can be to the team you know where the
team's so small and we have about 12
cars ourselves I feel like we don't we
don't talk too much about our cars but
you know so we're testing things but I
think people don't realize how many
varieties of cars out different each car
is
um and so it's super helpful to the team
to have that information when they're
doing bug reports
we have time for a few more questions
down here I'm gonna great I will come
back over
so I'm just gonna reword a question I
think I heard because I think it was a
really important one okay so you have a
closet or room of Hardware that runs
hardware and loop tests you might also
have some infrastructure that can run
tests like unit tests yeah when are
times when that Hardware or
infrastructure sort of maxes out because
you have too many requests to run tests
or do you not observe
it's this is where an open source
project GitHub gives us um GitHub
actions Runners for free
um we actually like upgraded our GitHub
plan so we get more concurrent Runners
and it was like I don't know a few
hundred dollars more a month and we just
get unlimited CI from GitHub uh every
month because we're an open source
product so that's really cool and then
as far as the hardware test we have to
scale those sometimes
um and we just add more devices in the
closet that's a little bit hard to
maintain
um because the team is so small but
um we're generally able to keep up with
that
you guys the testing closet is like a
night
it's very loud it's very important yeah
I keep it right next to my desk I don't
know how a deep Works around all the
alerts
oh yeah I just have a question about
like say safety which is related to like
a total model failures so I had a
situation one day it might sound just
unbelievable but like a bird like took a
dump and it hit on right where the
camera is looking and it covered a lot
of the camera and then the car uh the
model didn't like it didn't give any
warnings or but it was a model failure
and the car just went straight and I I
had it immediately disengage and turn on
my windshield wiper
um so like for and also others like uh
sometimes the model like incorrectly
predicts where the curb is and it rides
on the curb and stuff like that but when
it does that it there's no indication
that there is a model failure happening
um and it doesn't there's no loud beeps
or anything like I have you guys
considered maybe like putting in like a
warning system for like yes so two
things that you use the word safety um
we have to be very careful about how we
talk about safety so I thought a little
bit about this we have a safety model
and to recap that it guarantees that
if you press you're always able to
retake control by pressing on the brake
or the cancel button and it'll never do
anything too quickly for an attentive
driver to take over
um so if that fails that's perhaps a
safety failure
um but anything that the model does or
open pilot does is essentially
considered qm so your events are
considered bad quality
um
so it's just important to make the
distinction there and then as far as
those things we had this alert that kind
of detected device following model
uncertain we just found there was too
many false positives you would be pretty
annoyed if you got one when it was very
clear you shouldn't have gotten one so
we we can revisit this this was maybe a
year ago that we removed it but uh
I mean I hope that the bird one was
pretty obvious for an attentive driver
I do have a question on safety so uh
earlier we mentioned that there's uh
we're going to increase or maximize the
low speed torque so there are some
collaborators in in the community let's
say for Subaru or for Hyundai hjt
um that they want to get involved in the
state the implementation of the low
speed torque now uh we talked about that
we have to do injection testing and
we're getting more data and more
documentations on how the testings were
done so is there anything that is moving
forward from the open pilot team that
can provide some of that documentation
publicly on how the community can get
involved with that so we can kind of
speed up the process or you know
anything like that so the thing that's a
little bit hard for the community to do
is to get from zero to one on this
um so I would suggest that the community
you know Waits until we do it for the
first car which will probably be our ev6
because that's what we did for the taco
car there's a the first implementation
of it in the taco Branch for that car
and then the community is really good at
taking from what do we go to zero to one
and saying okay let's ship this on all
250 of our cars
um so I think that's the appropriate
time for the community to get involved
but the safety stuff is pretty
accessible if somebody wants to just get
ahead of this breed ISO 15622 and ISO 11
270 they're very readable they even
provide testing procedures
um so yeah we've got a question of
stairs
hey thanks a nice presentation I was
curious if you guys uh also track the
code coverage
you do okay cool uh what tool what tool
do you use uh so we track it with
codecav um that's a 70 right now
but uh it doesn't really cover
everything uh I mean that 70 doesn't
cover everything so it's really quite a
bit higher
um but we really
better code coverage than just like line
count that's probably a project that we
should do soon
because it's not completely obvious it's
something that like a few of us have in
our heads
um
but it's not completely obvious to an
external contributor like I'm making a
change is this covered by the tests
generally the answer is yes especially
for the things that the community tends
to want to change
but uh
it's uh yeah it's something we should
drive up and we should really
communicate when you're making a change
whether uh whether it's covered by the
test and how well it is
I think that's what you really want with
code coverage yeah yeah cool well sense
we've got one last question here
hey yeah uh general question what does
your system look like for learning from
Real World edge cases
so that's another question for the
research team okay
all right thank you so much adiem
thank you